[Music]
kids may be silly but some things that
they come up with are absolutely genius
stay tuned to find out how to watch
movies on your phone hands-free are you
new around here don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up and subscribe
to the things for more great videos now
on to 20 kids ideas that were pure
genius no pants some kids are just pure
genius is they aren't caught up in all
the stupid things that keep adults in
line one Twitter user found out that
when they tried to argue with their
two-year-old about the importance of
wearing pants after 30 minutes they just
gave up and both the parent and the
two-year-old Saten ate donuts with no
pants see that just proves that pants
are completely unnecessary wouldn't the
world be a better place if we all just
sat and ate doughnuts with no pants on
we would all certainly be a lot happier
petty banana have you ever been so mad
at someone that you just knew that you
had to get them back for whatever they
did to you of course we all have the
trouble comes in trying to figure out
exactly how to get them back without
going overboard well one kid definitely
figured it out Victor Pope jr. tweeted
that his son got mad at him and when it
opened up all the bananas in the house
that is absolute genius because as you
know once bananas are peeled they don't
last for very long good for you kid we
would have never thought of such genius
payback Lego wall when you were a kid
you probably had to take turns using
toys and other things with your siblings
wasn't that super annoying well this one
kid has figured out how to ensure that
no one bothers him while he has his time
on the computer how you might ask well
if he simply put Legos all around his
chair if you've ever stepped on a Lego
then you know that no one is going
anywhere near him as long as those Legos
are surrounding him it's probably the
most genius protective idea that we've
ever heard of we'll have to keep that
one in mind next time we need to protect
something cartoons or couch tunes do you
ever sit and wonder about the origin of
words probably not most adults just
accept words for what they are without
even thinking but this one kid brings up
a great point she wondered if you
watched cartoons on the couch would they
then become couch tunes great question
right why are they even called cartoons
to begin with no one really ever watches
them
car bed tunes or couch tunes would make
more sense they could even call them TV
tunes but cartoons make absolutely no
sense someone give this girl a medal for
pointing this out we wonder how many
other words make no sense that we've
just been going along with candy corn
pizza are you tired of the same old
meals then maybe you need to let a kid
pick out your dinner seriously just look
at this James Break well said that he
lets his three-year-old make her own
dinner one night and guess what she did
she put candy corn on top of cold pizza
can you think of anything better the
sweetness of the candy corn matched with
the savoriness of the pizza magnifique
why are there no restaurants that only
serve food made by children wouldn't
that be the best they would probably
serve hamburgers with gummy worms and
soda and starbursts YUM
word games have you ever spent hours and
hours trying to master a crossword
puzzle and they always start out so
simply and then all of a sudden you're
three hours in and you haven't gotten
anywhere well this kid has got it all
figured out
maybe the crossword puzzles have never
been asking us to find the words listed
on the sheet but to simply find it if
we'd known that we would be finishing
crossword puzzles left and right kids
man they are really the gift that the
world needs they make everything so
simple that we feel stupid for not
thinking of it sooner more than one
Christmas
this entry is probably one of our
favorites it's absolutely hilarious
Jenny Pentland tweeted that she and her
husband were arguing one day and instead
of asking them what was wrong their kids
shouted yay two Christmases clearly the
kid was already thinking ahead to the
fact that if his parents didn't stop
arguing they would split up and then he
would get to spend Christmas with each
of them at their houses and that would
mean double the presents how smart is
that kid for thinking ahead like that if
we heard our parents arguing we would
probably be sad but not this kid he had
the sense to think ahead to all of those
presents smirk yay
brownie for you brownies are delicious
there is no debating that so how would
you feel if someone walked up to you and
gave you a brownie probably pretty
delighted right well not so fast
Wikipedia Brown tweeted that her cousin
walked up to her and said I heard you
wanted a brown e and instead of giving
her a delicious chocolaty treat he
handed her a cutout of the letter e on
brown paper cruel but absolutely genius
it's pretty much the joke of the century
what he should have done was told
everyone that he was making brownies and
got them all excited before revealing
his cutout letters
couch cushion have you ever been sitting
on your couch and had a hard time
getting comfortable sometimes the cush
is just aren't padding your seat the way
that you need them to and even worse
sometimes when you lay back you're not
at the right angle to see the television
well this kid has found a solution to
that instead of laying on the couch he
stands in the couch it's actually pretty
smart if you think about it that way
you're comfortable and you can see the
television the only problem is that
adults are probably too big to actually
fit in the couch cushion but hey if
you're little enough to fit just give
this hack a try living room jungle gym
working out can be expensive first you
have to buy a gym membership and then on
top of that you may have to pay a
trainer to give you personal training on
top of that you have to leave your house
and do know who has time for all of this
this kid has come up with a perfect hack
to save you time and money just turn
your living room into a jungle gym that
way you don't have to leave your house
and it's absolutely free the only
problem is that you might get seriously
injured but that's not so important
sippy cup picture this you're a kid and
you're in the middle of an intense play
session when suddenly you realize that
you're super thirsty your friend has
enough of her drink to share with you
but you don't have a cup to put it in
well what do you do
this kid has it figured out you just
take the head off of one of your Barbie
dolls flip it over and voila
a cool cup the great thing is that once
you're done drinking you can wipe the
Barbie head off and put it back on no
harm no foul now people might look at
you funny for drinking out of a Barbie
head but at least you weren't thirsty
anymore
sunglasses switch there is so much
pressure on people to be stylish these
days you have to wear the right outfit
for every occasion because of this a lot
of people end up having several of the
same things take shades for instance
some people have so many that they find
it hard to find which pair they want to
wear on a sunny day this kid has a
solution to that problem simply stack
the shades on your face you can wear
them all and then when you get tired of
one you can rotate them around until you
have a pair that you want absolutely
genius matching pets don't you just love
your pet if you don't then you may have
more problems than you think but for
those of us who do love our pets the
worst thing that we can think of is
losing them somewhere when you're in a
big crowd of people a pet can easily get
lost if they aren't on a leash but if
you were a matching hat with your pet
like this kid did then everyone will
know it's your animal so even if it does
get lost people will know that you are
the owner and return the pet to you
pretty foolproof plan don't you think
iPad master as we mentioned before
sometimes it's super hard to find the
perfect position to watch your shows and
then you have to find a good position
and you have to hold your head up the
whole time while you watch the show it
stinks
this kid has the solution to all of that
simply wedge yourself in between two
chairs and place your iPad on the floor
to watch in front of you that way the
chairs do all of the work and you're
just sitting pretty watching your
favorite show doesn't that sound like
the best idea ever try this at home and
then let us know how it goes but
remember we are not liable for any
accidents that occur dog food
why should dogs have all the fun their
food Bulls are so easily accessible all
they have to do is stick their face in
the bowl and voila
they're eating their favorite food we
aren't saying that you should start
eating dog food but this kid may be on
to something what if everyone just put
their own food
in a dog bowl did we could all just
shove our faces into our food it'd be a
lot quicker and there'd be no intensives
to have to wash afterwards we'd say it's
definitely worth a try wouldn't you
thirsty kid we've all been thirsty at
times when there was nothing around a
drink well if you're like this kid
you'll never be thirsty again all you
have to do to cure your thirst is to
jump in a fish tank and grab a straw
after that all your thirst worries will
soon be gone it's the perfect way to get
a drink and cool off if it's too hot
wherever you are just make sure there
are no fish in the tank first don't want
to crush them we wonder what his mom
would say when she came home and found
him sitting in the fish tank she
probably wasn't too happy but she
probably also doesn't understand genius
going outside as a kid restrictions are
everywhere your parents are always
telling you don't do this or don't do
that but some kids are so genius that
they find ways to get around these
restrictions take this kid for instance
his parents told him not to set a foot
outside and look neither one of his feet
is outside he has totally gamed this
system now he can enjoy the outdoors
without getting in trouble we bet his
parents didn't even punish him for this
how could you punish someone that is so
obviously a genius we would be too busy
laughing to punish him dog training
everyone wants a cute puppy but no one
wants to put in the work to train the
dog training takes so much time and
energy and most times it's not very fun
but this kid completely found a way
around that instead of watching YouTube
videos to learn how to train his dog and
then using what he learned to train the
dog he shows the video directly to the
dog it cuts out the middleman and almost
all the work for him if this method of
training actually works for them it
would completely change the way that
people train their dogs but somehow we
doubt that dogs will be able to pick up
things from 3 minutes of a YouTube video
playing outside back in the olden days
kids always went outside to play there
was nothing else to do but now the
internet exists and everything has
changed on top of that kids have so many
games to play that they barely have time
to go outside but this kid has figured
out how to plays video games and stop
his mom from nagging him to go out
play at the same time how you might ask
by just taking his computer outside
technically he is playing outside right
such a smart idea that is the beauty of
having Wi-Fi you can take your games
wherever you want to go movie watching
them now that we can stream movies on
our phones watching our favorite shows
and films has become super easy the only
problem is that it is so annoying to
have to hold your phone up for a whole
two hours that a movie takes to play but
what if there was a solution well this
kid found one just put your phone
facedown on a glass table and then lay
under the table you'll be able to see
the movie without having to use your
arms to hold it up for a ridiculously
long time it's a win-win now all we have
to do is go find a glass table that's it
for the 20 kids ideas that were pure
genius were you surprised by any of
these ideas let us know in the comments
thanks for watching
[Music]